[Music]
when you're in a
happy relationship as you are yeah and
you release a song called on my own
uh what's the conversation that happens
there are you like this is not about you
we break up
we break up and then i write a sad song
i'm adele call me adele
[Music]
she's always so supportive that she's
like this is she just checks in she's
like this isn't about me right and i'm
like no darling and she's like okay what
do you want for dinner it's great we
move on real quick the lyrics are just
so good what inspired on my own it's
coming off my last song which is super
sad and super emotional what's nice
about it is that we're able to have
two ways of dealing with the same thing
and two ways of saying okay one day i'm
gonna cry about this and be devastated
and the next day i'm going to dance it
off and say you know what's true you
want better on my own i'm obsessed you
want to be in the music video can we run
that by the label can you remember
i'm there tell me when and i will be
there
people obviously initially got to know
you from your work with elijah woods
that's jamie fine with the title like on
my own
there may be some you know internet
sleuths out there that are like this
song is about
that what people love to do is they say
oh who can we attach this to is it an x
is it eli is it is what who is it for me
it's no no guys this is finally a song
about me i'm very happy for him that you
know he's able to do what he loves this
was the kind of love they were talking
about we celebrate pride all year long
here at et canada pride is
you know
being proud of having the strength to be
who you are it's about being
proud of having the courage to be who
you are and who you are and who you love